تتلاحق والتطورات في اوكرانيا على جبهه
بخموت سوليدار في منطقه دونيت في ظل تقدم
روسي في هذه الاخيره لكن بالارتكاز علمي
للشيعه فاجنر فيبروس مالكها
برفقه مقاتلين داخل احد انفاق مناجم الملح
في سوليدار ليعلن سيطره قوته حصرا على
كامل المدينه توصف فاجنر بانها شركه
عسكريه خاصه ويراها اخرون اقرب ما تكون
الى مجموعه روسيه عسكريه شبه رسميه فهي
وحده تتمتع وفقا صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
بالاستقلاليه وتتبع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
يعتقد ان مؤسسها
ضابط سابقا في القوه الخاصه وحملت اسمه
السري فاجنر لكنها الان مملوكه لرجل
الاعمال
ويعرف باسم طباخ بوتين لاداره شركه
كونكورد المنظمه لحفظه الاستقبال
بالكريملاند وتضم مزيجا من مقاتلين لا
يقدمون خدماتهم مقابل المال
العمل لاول مره مع ضم روسيا لشبه جزيره
القرم في عام 2014 ونفذتها هجمات في شرق
اوكرانيا يقول مسؤولون بريطانيون ان عدد
مقاتل فاجنر ارتفع من نحو الفا الى ما
يقرب من 20,000 مقاتل في اوكرانيا اين نحو
عشره في المئه من اجمالي القوه الروسيه
على الارض افتتح بريكوجين اول مقر ليفاجنر
في مدينه سان بطرسبورغ الروسيه وقال في
بيانه مهمته مركز فاجنر هي توفير بيئه
مريحه لتوليد افكار جديده مغريه تحسين
القدره الدفاعيه لروسيا
وتحسين القدره دفاعيه لروسيا لا يمكنه
اخفاء حقيقه الاتهامات لبابنار بارسال
مسلحها الى عده دول في امريكا اللاتينيه
وافريقيا وتنفيذ ما توصفه بالعمليه القذره
في مناطق النزاعات مختلفه ففي سوريا
انتشرت فاجنر لدعم النظام السوري منذ 2016
خصوصا حول حقول النفط في دير الزور وخطفت
الاضواء اكثر بعد مقتل اعاده في غاره
امريكيه عام 2018
وتنشط المجموعه في ليبيا منذ 2016 وتدعم
القوات المواليه للواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر وكشف تقرير سري للامم المتحده وجود
اكثر من 1000 من عناصرها لكن تقرر اخرى
تقدرهم بالالاف كما تنتشر ميليشيا فاجنر
في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى لحراسه مناجم
الذهب والالماس وتشير تقارير الى وجود
الله في مدغشقر وموزمبيق والسودان وكان
اخر انتشار لها في مالي بعد انسحاب القوه
الفرنسيه من هناك